thousands of London residents are in
temporary shelters this morning fire
inspectors specters forced them to leave
for apartment buildings last night after
the buildings were determined to be
unsafe the inspections follow last
week's high-rise blaze that killed at
least 79 people Jonathan Vigliotti is on
the scene in London this morning
Jonathan good morning good morning we're
standing outside one of the buildings
that was evacuated last night some of
the residents we've heard from said they
were getting ready for bed when they got
that knock on their door and were told
their homes weren't safe to live in more
than 4000 people are currently displaced
and that number could actually increase
as officials work to identify other
hazardous buildings the decision was
made late last night residents ordered
to leave this North London high-rise
over mounting concerns about exposed gas
pipes and combustible exterior siding
known as cladding in the UK I had a fire
safety check done today why are they
left it to her past 8:00 at night to
start getting residents out where do
they think we're all going government
officials are scrambling to remove fire
hazards in at least 10 other buildings
in the wake of last week's deadly blaze
at Granville Tower that police now say
started in a faulty refrigerator and may
have been fueled by the cladding known
in the trade as aluminum composite
material or ACM the cladding in case is
a polyethylene core that's highly
flammable police are looking into why
and how it was installed we are looking
at every criminal offense for
manslaughter onwards we are looking at
every Health and Safety and fire safety
fences and we are reviewing every
investigator every company at the moment
involved in the building and
refurbishment of Grand Hotel one of
those companies New York based our
Connick supplied a component of the
cladding which they say should never be
used on buildings over 32 feet high but
in a statement to Reuters news agency
our Connick said it had known the
panel's would be used in Grenville Tower
but it was not its role to decide what
was or was not compliant with local
building regulations and officials are
now dealing with what has grown into a
health and safety crisis one resident I
spoke with who was understandably
frustrated said he was never told when
it would be safe for him to return back
home Dana
Jonathan Vigliotti in London thank you